so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Captain America's
shield in both the comics and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and what I'm hoping
is that at the end of all this you'll
have a stronger understanding of how it
works as well as why it's such a staple
of his characters identity
so in Marvel Comics the history of
Captain America shield
can actually be traced in line with the
history of Wakanda where Steve Rogers
was originally provided a shield
composed of a bulletproof metal in the
shape of a heater shield similar to the
designs of the 12th century in the
second issue of the original Captain
America comics the heater shield was
transitioned to a circular shield now
outside of the comics the reason for
this change came and that the magazine
publisher MLJ magazines had issued a
cease and desist letter to Marvel Comics
owing to the fact that the design of
Captain America's shield was identical
to that of a character owned by MLJ
magazines as a result artist Jack Kirby
we designed the shield giving it a
circular design now having said that in
terms of continuity in 2010 under writer
Reginald Hudlin the four-part miniseries
black panther Captain America Flags of
Our Fathers established that in the
months leading up to the end of world
war 2 Captain America and Nick Fury
alongside his Howling Commandos and let
a mission to halt the efforts of Adolf
Hitler Baron von Strucker
and Johann Schmidt from invading the
nation of Wakanda and seizing his
vibranium stores however during the
conflict Captain America's original
shield was destroyed but when the
efforts of the Nazis were staved off and
as a token of thanks
Azari the black panther at the time and
the grandfather of T'Challa had provided
Rogers with a sample of vibranium while
Steve Rogers and salt went on to have a
new shield Commission having said that
while the circular shield is a mainstay
of Steve Rogers its development came in
an attempt by metallurgist Myron MacLean
who was hired by the US government for
the purpose of using the vibranium
sample to produce an indestructible
shield for Rogers covenant Captain
America vol 1 issues 302 and 303 as well
as Avengers vol 1 issue number 66 these
stories established that during his
attempts to blend vibranium with a metal
alloy the accidental success led to the
formation of Captain America's shield
which exists as a form of vibranium
which has never been duplicated the
reason for this was due to the fact that
Myron had actually fallen asleep during
the blending process leaving him unable
to recreate it while he had attempted to
do so the resulting metal form from his
efforts came to be known as adamantium
as a result and in order to
differentiate between the two materials
the shield of Captain America is normal
fer to a zapper no adamantium vibranium
and exists as the only source of the
material while the material bonded the
Wolverine skeleton is referred to as
true adamantium and is actually slightly
weaker than the material of Captain
America shield now in terms of his
capabilities the shield of Captain
America is for all intents and purposes
completely indestructible by normal
means the reason for this comes with the
nature of vibranium and that by its very
design vibranium literally absorbs any
and all sound in kinetic energy directed
towards it and uses those energies to
enhance the metals properties meaning
that the harder Captain America's shield
is hit the stronger it becomes at the
same time the proto adamantium within
the shield serves as a kind of
reinforcement to the vibranium metal
making the shield more durable than it
would have been if it were composed
entirely of vibranium by itself
however the shield's ability to absorb
sound and kinetic energy produced during
the attacks has its limits and that if
enough energy is exerted on the shield
at one time the shield itself would be
destroyed entirely while this has
happened on several occasions the most
notable of these came during the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline when Thanos
had used a power gym within the gauntlet
to shadow Captain America's shield with
a single hip and beams like Franklin
Richards Owen Reese or Matcham Jasper's
who possess enough power to control the
molecular structure of matter can simply
eliminate the shield entirely or
transform it into something else now
regarding Rogers use of the shield were
common belief holds that the shield may
contain some kind of magnets or psychic
link to Rogers and static his ability to
throw the shield and have a return to
him is actually just a byproduct of a
Super Soldier Serum because the formula
enhances all the attributes of Rogers
both physical and mental while it
doesn't make him a scientific genius it
enhances understanding of geometry and
trigonometry allowing him to throw the
shield at certain angles to ensure that
the ricochet process would bring the
shield back to him while achieving his
desired attack in the process the way
the Marvel Cinematic Universe aside from
the benefits of enhanced speed strength
durability and reflexes that came with
Rogers exposure to project rebirth
Captain America has a unique fighting
style and that he isn't a
straightforward smashing machine and
instead implements a combination of
martial art styles like kickboxing
Taekwondo judo and American boxing
alongside military strategy to this in
Steve
Rogers is able to use the shield as an
extension of his own body ricocheting
off objects to strike enemies in
unexpected ways
as a result rogers is often seen
changing others attacks or using the
environment in battle such as bashes the
shield off multiple opponents are going
from a straight attack to a choke as it
was seen in the Winter Soldier fight at
the same time fighting offensively with
only a shield is an unheard-of concept
and that even within Marvel Comics
some of the most skilled fighters
including daredevil taskmaster in
Elektra fight with a combination of
martial arts swords stays size or even
guns this combined with the reflective
properties of the shield and Captain
America's already augmented fighting
prowess are greatly increased by way of
distraction and disorientation
now following Steve Rogers undertaking
the super-soldier formula during project
rebirth in the first Captain America
film instead of immediately seeing
battle instead he was primarily used to
tour around the United States in a
colorful Captain America costume for the
purpose of propaganda during this time
this shared he carried was a throwback
to the original Captain America comic
Sheila 1940's and that Steve Rogers
donned a heater shaped shield similar to
those used in Europe during the 12th
century but was paid to resemble the
American flag now with a movie would go
on to reveal the Bucky Barnes had been
taken prisoner alongside multiple
soldiers who would go on to form the
Howling Commandos after returning from
the rescue mission and re-entering world
war ii as a fighting soldier Howard
Stark presented Steve Rogers with a
discus shaped shield that's actually
synonymous with Captain America got a
sidetrack here and delve into a bit of
history of vibranium in the MCU prior to
World War Two Howard Stark discovered
vibranium while exploring one of the
deepest jungles in Wakanda which was
used to craft the shield made out of the
material and bring it back to the United
States now what we won't know much about
Wakanda as a society until the
introduction of black panther during an
after Civil War because agent Ultron saw
ulysses klaw operating as a black market
dealer in vibranium and because Wakanda
has remained him from the world and the
larger MCU until now it can largely be
assumed that Howard Starks entry into
Wakanda was not sanctioned and much like
ulysses klaw the vibranium attained by
Howard Stark was done so illegally and
smuggled out of the country having said
that the known properties of vibranium
are that it's stronger than steel but
only a third of the weight and it's
completely vibration absorbent meaning
it could absorb or deflect nearly
all kinetic or energy based attacks
something to also point out here is that
during the events of Avengers when Ford
hit Captain America shield was hammer if
the nature of vibranium in the MCU held
true to the comics the impact would have
made no sounds of any kind but be that
as it may much like the comics Captain
America shield does have its limits as
witness at age of Ultron the limits of
Rogers shield came by way of Ultron
himself and that because both Ultron's
body and Captain America's shield are
composed completely a vibranium when a
combination of visions binds stone
powered energy beam Iron Man's repulsors
and lightning bolts from the ol near
were able to melt away Ultron's outer
shell the Ottoman produced by Marvel was
that with sufficient heat or energy the
absorption principles of vibranium were
capable of being completely overwhelmed
Hemi said that there are several unique
things you have the shield which
differentiate it from his comical
counterpart the combination of the
shield's design and it's vibrating
properties make this shield nearly
immune to wind resistance allowing me to
travel as hard and as fast as Captain
America wants it to in addition to this
it has a unique ricochet property
allowing it to reflect off of objects
and lose very little momentum in the
process as an example in Captain America
the First Avenger
during the motorcycle chase scene
Captain America was shown to throw the
shield have it ricochet and strike
several enemies before catching it
mid-flight furthermore during the
Avengers film Iron Man's repulsor beams
were reflected off the shield against
the dattari an army a feat that's
remained unseen in the comics so far
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and hopefully
you guys enjoyed this discussion about
Captain America shield and I'm actually
thinking about doing a video on Captain
America's fighting styles which I think
would be pretty cool let me know what
you guys think about that in the
description and I will catch you guys
later peace